All right,
we've learned a lot in this lesson.
Let's take a quick recap before
we move on to the last exercise.
We covered what ARIA does
to the accessibility tree.
Essentially, ARIA allows you to
intervene and do some tree surgery
before the accessibility tree is
exposed to assistive technology.
>From changing the role name or
properties of a single element
through to actually removing or
moving parts of the tree route.
We talked about how to use the role
attribute to modify the role
of a single element.
We saw how to use the ARIA spec to find
information about roles and attributes.
For example, we can use the ARIA
spec to find a specific role
then dive down into the detailed
information for that role, to
learn about what attributes it supports
and what default semantics it may have.
Similarly, we can find information
about particular aria properties.
We learnt how to use ARIA
extended labeling options.
Aria-label, to provide a screen
reader only label string.
Aria-labeledby, to refer to some
visible element as a label.
And aria-describedby, to provide some
extra information alongside the label.
We looked at the way ARIA can
specify semantic relationships
beyond the labeledby and
describedby relationships.
Such as aria-owns to modify
the shape of the accessibility tree.
We examine the default semantics
of native HTML elements, and so
that some of those semantics may
not be overridden with ARIA.
We learned that ARIA has
a set of landmark and
document structure roles to help users
navigate and understand page structure.
We looked at how to hide things
from assistive technology.
Or show things only to
assistive technology.
And lastly, we spent some time
exploring Aria-live regions.
This is really only the very
basics of ARIA, but
it should be enough to help you
understand what ARIA can offer and
how to read and understand the ARIA
documentation to learn more.